[Music]
i was overweight
so i decided i need to do something and
it was this younger guy kind of
motivated me too
he challenged me to a to a little door
as well
that motivated me you know really you
know start eating better and exercise
i say okay y'all see me now but wait you
see me later it's gonna be different
and it seemed like it happened overnight
even though
it was 90 days you know i was so focused
on eating keto diet and uh it helped me
tremendously
i found out through dr wallach that you
need to put yourself you need to put
your body first
you need to put your health first i
started 217
and i went down to 152 there's some
young guys
made in high school at 17 and 18 years
old now
9 you i am 57 almost 58.
how can i run them in the 40s i'm almost
getting granddaddy
it's amazing i really feel like about 24
years old
most people when they want to start a
challenge or start losing weight or
start
lifting weights or whatever they always
say i'm gonna start monday
you start that day don't but you keep
putting it off it's not gonna happen
people are always coming up to me asking
me how did i do this
how did i lose this weight how did i
change my body like i did
and i tell them about the products of
youngevity
and what they need to do it works
you